so here's the problem okay and what
usually gets presented to you is have a
look at the whole thing it starts like
this okay
and when you have a look at this what it
appears to be is one big triangle that's
cut into patients yes
so muscles good and you can look at the
dimensions of the triangle it's got a
high of lips like five yeah and help me
count what's the width or the base
driver
what's this no tape yeah right see this
five by 13 triangle okay now in the
animation and you can verify you can see
what's going on these two pieces have
swathes but then these two pieces have
been rearranged a little bit and
suddenly you've got the same fine by you
can count it and double-check five by 13
triangle right
but now there's a whole price so the
area of this triangle Kyung is well it's
55 by 13 on to right which i think is 32
and a half units yes
but then you have a look at this big and
you're like well it's going to be that
32 and a half units minus 1 because this
there's something which isn't covered by
a colored favorite so how is it that
just by rearranging we have made a
square disappear okay
take it
/ the area that's covered by the pool
like the square yeah but the parts of
the splat that change okay good right
let's go on this idea slant is exactly
the nature of the problem I think if you
could summarize what's the problem with
this because that it's not really a pair
of spinach eat really it's an optical
illusion
okay the reason why is slant is the
issue
it looks like remember I said it looks
like it's triangle doesn't it okay this
thing but in fact it is it is not a
triangle at all
it is actually a quadrilateral do I give
very good okay so there's a couple of
ways you can talk about this right
because you guys know tree it might be
easiest to talk about it in those terms
that you can see it with that okay have
a look at the blue triangle you can see
that it's dimensions are two by five
right - by fine
but if you have a look at this triangle
here it's a it's three by eight I
believe right three by eight which is
both the same these these two triangle
are not similar they look similar but
they're not actually similar okay now
because they're not similar you can use
tree to do this better
actually yeah let's do that any
calculators out now suppose I just
rephrase the question of it it is drawn
on a grid so even though the triangles
are poor they appear they are still
right angle triangles tsipras's let's
have a look at the blue one I've got a
right angle here okay so use tree how
might we determine for instance what the
size of this angle is how would we work
on it son yes Chad wouldn't you because
you got to you got fine that's opposite
and adjacent right so you'd say ten of
that angle let's call it theta is 2 over
5 yes
which gives you theta equals tan inverse
all to this which someone could tell me
just give me nearest degree 22
22 degrees okay so I can write 22
degrees up here but when you have a look
at this angle right instead of 10
inverse of 2/5
it's really tainted but solve 3/8 now
what's that's the nearest degree 21
degrees now 21 degrees 22 degrees you
and me we can't tell what the difference
is between those okay and what you have
a look at that it looks pretty straight
doesn't it one degree difference than
one you can tell okay but in fact if I
made it really obvious you know this
degrees it is smaller so it's something
like this and then you've got a
different triangle up there right then
you got your bits and pieces in here
okay so this is an exaggerated beauty of
course it doesn't work because this
shape is not a triangle you see this is
gap if you see this gap right now that
gap is where this gap comes wrong right
it's not very big but over this space
it's just big enough to make a little
square okay because if you think about
it when they swap places okay instead of
being like this shape you're going to
get this shape okay so you can see how
this one bends in width and this one
bends outwards right see there's there's
where the imaginary triangle is okay so
from bending inwards to bending outwards
there's some missing area in here so
that's why I got paralyzed okay